When we talk about Virtualization.
When we look at CPUs in memory.
Certain things are relatively
less complicated,
in spite of everything that we said,
so far.
Because there is a significant
level of standardization
at the instruction set architecture,
across different platforms.
So then from
a Virtualization standpoint,
we know that we have to
support a specific ISA.
And then we don't care if there
are lower level differences
between the hardware because it's up
to the hardware manufacturers to be
standardized at the ISA level.
This clearly is the case for
a particular ISA for instance, for
x86 things will be different across
x86 and for instance MIPS platforms.
When we look at devices however,
there is a much greater diversity in
the types of devices, if we compare that
to the types of CPU instruction sets.
And also there is lack of
standardization when it comes to
the specifics of the device interface
and the semantics of that interface,
so what is the behaviour when
a particular call is invoked.
How a particular device
should respond to
a call to send the packet for instance.
To deal with this diversity,
Virtualization solutions adopt
one of three key models,
to virtualize devices.
We will describe these models, next.
And note that they were developed
before any Virtualization friendly
hardware extensions were made to the,
CP architectures and the chip sets.
And these new modifications
of the hardware
make some aspects of device
Virtualization much simpler than
than what originally it was when
these models were first introduced.